alright guys let's stop procrastinating
okay I need segment ideas well I have a
few ideas of course are you we could do
a man on the street segment called ask
aunty where you go up to different
uncles and aunties and ask them their
opinions at different times no I'm
laughing at how wack it is racist come
here what you got for me all right so we
go to this club we talk to some
beautiful women uh-huh an interview
beautiful I like that that's done thanks
for subbing Wilde Oh better okay
all right fair enough one minute what
you got for me well I think we should
also be appealing to the female
demographic does anything about that
girl like exploring how ethnic wear has
been making its way into mainstream
fashion that's why she's here to appeal
to the [ __ ] beautiful that's
respectful Prashant what you got for me
okay
political commentary on post 9/11
Islamophobia between Muslims and Sikhs
you know and all the issues that eight
crimes have been coming up right you
know the Sudan laughing at you okay I
think we open my zone down as soon as it
political but hey keep trying man you're
honest on with that I'm sure you are
alright anybody else well we could do
something fun you know like a civil
rights leaders as roommates Martin
Luther King and Gandhi are roommates and
they get along and then maybe Malcolm X
is there across the hall and they're
like at odds with each other Wow
anybody else got anything bottle service
gender equality in rural India okay
definitely sticking with Islamophobia
there's a lot to go over there listen I
mean let's think of some you know I mean
this is all good but let's let's get
some hot [ __ ] you know what I mean fires
ahh
well I'd been watching you stand up so I
think your tops abilities stop kissing
ass we could do a ghetto spoof on Jim
Cramer's mad money give us where it's
called mad money and it just you being
like a hustler and go on talking about
the economy and the market you just say
bad buddy do you not even understand how
offensive these ideas are possibly what
is it then please get up how about there
just go you know I had enough no what no
she just go that's enough I'm gonna get
some coffee yeah yes and coffees alright
get some coffee from uptown listen man
coffee does yeah yo go get me a coffee
all right so we're stealing all of his
ideas seriously that was like pretty a
million Wow oh good about the club
segment that was horrible everything you
said was just awful terrible Oh like
that Shh sighs please stop